our chief medical correspondent dr john
lapook joins us now dr lapu good morning
to you
i want to begin with the president's
comments that we should not let kovit
dominate our lives and not be afraid of
it what was your reaction when you heard
him say that
you know tony you may not want to let it
dominate
your life uh but it is having a huge
effect on all of our lives
and you have to have a healthy respect
for a virus that's wrecked so many lives
around us not just the people who have
died but the people
who are the families of the people who
dies and people who have recovered and
have still have symptoms
so you know this was an opportunity for
a teaching moment for the country
where you could go out there and say
look this is serious and here's what you
can do
just don't sit around being afraid you
want to wear a mask
you want to have social distancing and
we heard from the cdc yesterday that now
aerosols can go beyond six feet
so if you're indoors you want to have
adequate ventilation and even more of a
reason to wear a mask
indoors so there are things there are
messages it was an opportunity
to teach i want to pick up on the idea
of respect for the virus because we saw
the president there take off his mask
when he returned to the white house the
white house is a residence but it
is also the world's most famous office
building people work there
how contagious is the president at this
point
we have to assume that the president
still is contagious that he's
shedding virus we know that can happen
for about up to 10 days
after somebody that you're not
considered free of the ability to infect
somebody else
for about 10 days after you develop
symptoms so we have to assume he's still
infectious
again we know that this virus can spread
through the air yes it may
spread to people who are within six feet
but it absolutely can spread beyond six
feet
and so you have to think what's the
ventilation system in the white house
are
are everybody wearing is everybody
wearing a mask there and i think you
have to have respect for
not just the president of the united
states which of course you want him to
be safe but for everybody else everybody
all the employees there have to be safe
it's a little bit misleading to suggest
the president has been discharged from
the hospital more accurate to say the
hospital has gone home with him he has
an icu there yes
in the white house so i am curious dr
lapu what's ahead
for him in terms of treatment and care
yeah i tony you you've got it exactly
right i spoke to somebody
who was intimately familiar with the
abilities of the white house and he said
it's kind of almost like a step down
unit
which is just one level below an
intensive care unit so i look at it more
like a transfer to another medical
facility
and they're going to still be looking at
him very closely you know he's going to
get intravenous
rem deserve that's an iv drug they're
going to be looking at his vital signs
all the time i don't know what other
tests they're doing because they're not
telling us that
but we heard that there are physicians
there are nurses physical therapists
i would be shocked if there's not an
anesthesiologist there just in case
he developed shortness of breath so we
know that first week
people can have symptoms that that can
be serious but they may they may be
relatively milder
than the second week when you suddenly
get inflammation this inflammatory phase
and that's where people can really very
quickly go south uh when i was in april
in
nyu langone on the coveted wards i was
taking care of patients and people would
come into the hospital
and it looked like they were fairly okay
and that suddenly they would take a turn
for the worse and an hour later have a
breathing tube
you keep hearing those kind of stories
john i'm curious about the the
the president's doctor you know because
there's still so many answers that we
don't know we still don't know when he
last tested negative that seems that
that would be important to know
but the doctor keeps saying you know
hipaa rules how does a doctor balance
the patient's need for doctor patient
confidentiality
and the public's need or curiosity to
know what is happening with the
president
because if the president said you can
share the information wouldn't it be
shared
right so it's not up to the doctor to do
that balance it's up to the patient
the patient whether it's the president
united states or you or me
uh we we have we have the right to say
what
information is going to be released
publicly so what we're seeing here is a
filtering of the information right
it's not like we're saying look it's
hipaa protected and we don't want to
hear
uh i don't want anything told we're
saying kind of here's the good news
and when there might be some less than
good news like does he have pneumonia
does he have an increase in inflammatory
markers in his blood
that we're not hearing so that's where
it gets a little bit hard for people
like me
we don't want to be on the outside
looking in and having all this
conjecture and speculating
uh we'd like to have more information
and we certainly are not his doctor his
doctors are his doctor
john there there's no um there's no
evidence so far that the white house is
actually doing any contact tracing
is that a concern and if the white house
was a typical business
might it have been shut down to be
cleaned at this point
yeah i i think that is a huge question
you know we found out that the centers
for disease control
who have tremendous expertise in doing
contact tracing or directing contact
tracing
are on the sidelines here it's like you
know you had an olympic athlete
who's training for the olympics for
years and years and then oh you're on
the sideline
why not call them in get their expertise
yes you want to be able to have contact
tracing and you want to be
able to get specimens from everybody and
have save them
for molecular fingerprinting genetic
fingerprinting so that later on you can
figure out
where to start not to point figures but
to say how can we prevent this from
happening in the future
and what about shutting the white house
down
i i think you want to have a deep
cleaning for sure but
the thing that i would concentrate on
the most tony
uh and anthony is that this can spread
through the air
we know that now without a doubt so
what's the ventilation and is
every single person wearing a mask i
cannot stress that enough
all right john lope thank you so much